all right well we'll start off with you
all right i think you guys can actually
go ahead onsite if that works
with david
you guys went on um i think a 75 to 30
run after
falling down 13 early what allows uh you
guys to have
success like that over a sustained
period of time
a run like that paying attention to
detail
um i don't think i don't think in the
beginning that we were um
physical enough um and
you actually you have to get a feel for
how hard miami plays
um and i think um you know they smacked
us in the mouth
and we got a sense of that and so we
knew how hard we had to play if we
wanted to try to make it a game
and um you know from that moment when it
was 23-10
we started to play um to our
capabilities we started flying around we
started getting defensive stops and
started sharing the ball a lot better
offensively and just gotten to a really
good group
all right um thank you
for a.d obviously his first finals game
would you see it
out about his preparation was there any
advice you gave him
and to see him perform like that um
what do you feel about that um i don't
feel anything
i expected out of him um didn't need to
give him
no advice we've been preparing for this
moment all season
he's been preparing for this moment all
season and i'm happy to be on the same
floor with him in the same uniform
and uh he was once again a force
um every facet of the game both
offensively and defensively
lebron you've felt the buzz of the nba
finals
nine times in your career what was it
like today
with nobody there the sound i mean i
know you're used to bubble basketball at
this point but
on this stage what did it feel like to
play a finals game
i felt great felt great i've been
preparing for this moment for quite a
while
um and fans know fans
um the inner challenge for myself
and the way i prepared myself it felt
amazing to be playing in the finals once
again
okay rachel nichols
brian you've seen plenty of times over
the years where if one team has a bunch
of injuries the other team
kind of floats a little bit and doesn't
come at them as hard
how do you make sure that you guys don't
do that in game two
we got so much more work to do
the job is not done we're not satisfied
we're winning one game
is that simple
chris
there was a few times where you guys got
up big
and then uh there's a lot of celebrating
going on and you know
i've seen you sometimes you you have to
bring them in a little bit
what what do you um from your experience
what have you seen in the past that that
got you to the point where you felt like
sometimes you just say like okay let's
let's keep it on task
uh the best teacher in life is
experienced and i've experienced
moments in my career finals games
where you had all the momentum in the
world and you felt like you had the game
under control
one play here or one play there could
change the course of a series or change
the course of a game
and one in particular that always rings
home for me
um it's game two the 2011 finals
in miami versus dallas um d wade hits a
three
right by that bench uh i believe put us
up
either 13 or 17. and from that moment on
dallas went on a hell of a run and
finished it off with a dirt and whiskey
left hand layup
to steal that game that [ __ ] burns me
to this day so i always talk about the
best teacher in life is experience so
i've experienced a lot so
that's what prompt me to be who i am
today
is being able to have those experiences
okay we'll send it back to will right
thank you we're gonna take three more on
my side tanya
lebron i'm wondering in a game like this
when you guys have the kind of lead
that you had are you already thinking um
this is what we've done this is what we
could do better here are some things
that we're doing wrong
were you already in that frame of mind
during this game
yeah absolutely um i was
i think you could learn so much more
from uh from a win
than you can in a loss and
i can't wait to get
you know for tomorrow for us to get back
together and watch the film
and see ways we can be better and see
some of the breakdowns that we had
you know especially in that fourth
quarter especially in that first six
minutes of the first quarter
uh where we could be so much better
defensively
and also so much better offensively so i
can't wait
i'm extremely um amped up about watching
the film with our with our but with our
ball club tomorrow
i'm gonna watch some tonight obviously
um you know by myself
but looking forward to getting together
as a group tomorrow
hey lebron mike trudeau back in l.a
teams have spent
your whole career trying to keep you out
of the paint you say the same thing this
season about a.d
what are some of the ways that you guys
are still always seemingly able to get
there
still able to get to the rim and still
able to finish
because we have a great spacing and
great shooters without kcp
without danny green dow kyle kuzma
and markeith morris and and a list of
guys that can spread the floor
um it allows myself and a.d to be able
to do the things that we do
um in the interior and we try to mix up
our game too
you know we try to mix it in um in the
interior and exterior
but you know when you have you know guys
that can space the floor
like we have it allows us to do some of
the things that we do in the paint
all right last one on my side brad
lebron why is rondo so opposed to being
called playoff rondo
and did you guys see some of that in the
first half especially
i'm not sure i've never called him that
um we've never called him that
we only call him dope um so that would
be a dull question
but you know just having him in this
moment
having him on our on our side and um you
know i think he mentioned yesterday or
you know whatever media day was for the
finals that
you just don't you never know you don't
get these moments a lot
and um you know it's been over a decade
since he's been in the finals and
you know and i think he's just you know
cherishing the moment but also just
you know just playing the game that he
loves to play the cerebral way
uh the determined way and the
championship way
um as he's been playing for quite a
while now
we have any more here all right thank
you
thank you
alrighty well we'll start on your end
all right thank you mike trudell please
hey anthony of course your first finals
game tonight uh 14
of your field goal attempts came in the
paint wondered if that had anything to
do with a specific mindset with the
match up or with
anything about the way you approach this
game
i just want to come out with a lot of
energy um
you know be aggressive on the offensive
glass
you know playing in a dunker's area
you know when brian and doe and ac get
in the paint
they got easy dump offs and not settling
for too many jumpers just being able to
you know play in the paint and just kind
of dominate the paint area
that was kind of my mindset coming into
the game
hey anthony you said on the broadcast
that you had
a few nerves before the game before the
ball went up
just how it how it felt different in in
what ways it might have felt different
from
other uh postseason experiences you've
had uh getting that first taste of the
finals
just the finals uh first time i i am uh
experiencing this so
you know obviously you want to come out
and play well and you want to come out
and win
um like i've always put pressure on
myself
and i had the same thing game one of the
western conference finals as well so
you know when the ball gets tipped up
all that goes away and it's just
basketball but everything leading up to
it
you know you're very excited your
adrenaline is gone
early you know because you're so excited
just to be here and get ready to go out
there and play so
you know you know it went away early but
uh
it was a great experience for him a
great game one you know job's not done
we got three more allison
we'll start off with kyle
been really tough i'm sure you would
love to have more of your family
for your playoff problem what did it
mean to you to have your dad
um watching you in this game and seeing
your first finals and to play so well
it means a lot i mean he uh
you know forced my mom to you know do
that seven day quarantine to be here
so for him you know to he's always been
the one to you know go to all my games
you know in a home market you know not
more so on the road but
um you know he's extremely proud of me
um
you know for him to be here essentially
courtside to watch
watch me in my first finals game means a
lot to me
you know we just got to finish it off i
mean you know he
you know he wants us to win he wants me
to be a champion
um so it's a little bit more pressure
you know coming from him but um it was
fun it was fun seeing him course
watching me in that first game
i'm sorry david
so you had 34 tonight um which is tied
for third
for a laker debut in the finals so
shaq's
juan then mike and then you and bayley
are tied
when you hear those names obviously
laker history is such a part of the
experience
of playing for the team but when you
hear those names what do you think about
it and
you know do you have goals of being
remembered the same way they are
and always be associated as a laker yeah
um
it's a great honor to be in that
category with those guys i mean it's
they've done so much for the game hall
of famers and
um for me to you know come out and
perform that way and you know be
mentioned with those guys
especially just as a laker you know with
the biggest franchise in basketball um
you know them guys that you watch film
on that you idolize and now to
you say be in that category is
definitely a huge honor for me
um like i say
what makes it even more you know sweeter
is
you know winning it and so um
obviously that's a great you know honor
but i also want to be
mentioned in categories with champions
you know so that's that's that's the
next step but
the accolades along the way you know the
list i'm i'm able to
to join along the way is definitely
something you don't think about it's
just kind of happening we go out there
and play but
it's definitely a great honor
you mentioned wanting to be aggressive
um with their zone
are there i think a lot of times people
want to just shoot over them
was that something that you guys caught
really focus on still finding seams and
trying to get easy baskets
yeah i mean this team plays a lot of his
own they play a lot of zone in the
regular season a lot auto zone in the
playoffs
so and they've been very effective
they won series with playing zone and we
knew they were going to try to
run zone against us i mean the two
regular season games we played they ran
zone
and we just try to find ways to exploit
it um
and make them come out of the zone or
they stay in it you know make them pay
for being in zone but they're
a team run zone who knows how to play it
it's our job to find
you know the gaps in the zone to be
successful
hey i know you want to be um you know
wish you were playing in staples center
right now but
does it feel coming into this game did
it feel like a nba finals
match did you feel any different from
the other playoff games been playing
here
um yeah i mean you see the decals on the
floor
you see all the people in the stands
essentially you see uh
the the patch on the back of the jersey
patch on the saudi warm-ups
so you kind of see that as a finals game
but like i said once you go out there
and start playing
yeah i don't think the fans are allowed
to make any noise so
it feels like a regular game you know in
a bubble
um even though that pressure uh the
finals is still there
and so i think it makes a lot easier for
you know
especially our guys to just go out there
and play um
you know but and staples have been
a lot crazy i mean just playing in front
of your home fans and sharing these
moments with them
but i think just being here it
definitely
it definitely calmed the nerves a lot
faster
we'll send it back to well for the last
view all right yeah i want to take two
more
um tanya please a.d i wondered what the
how much of an emphasis was there on
making sure that
you win early given how miami has gotten
off to really good starts in
all of their other series uh we just
want to
you know be a team to apply pressure um
you know they
won all their game ones um
we lost two and one one but we want to
be able to
you know come out and essentially take
care of home court
but i mean we want to win every game we
play you know we never want to
come out and lose
you know we came out we came out very
slow the first
five six minutes at the first quarter uh
and they got hot
down 15. and uh kcp kind of saved saved
us in that first quarter with the two
threes and then we kind of got going on
both ends of the floor so
we can't come out sluggish knowing that
this team is you know a team that can
get high
from three and you know get to the
free-throw line and get to the paint so
we have to be able to come out a little
bit more aggressive and
come out with a little bit more sense of
urgency to start the games and that's on
the starters
especially me and brian but you know you
know it feels good to get the first game
um you know we don't we're not satisfied
we don't like how we ended the game
um there wasn't a championship mentality
mentality and you know we have to be
better
in that regard but we'll take the win
but
we'll watch film and and try to get game
two as well
all right last one for you melissa
roland
hey a.d you alluded to this yesterday
you said some guys have loved playing in
the bubble
i'm curious are you one of them and if
so why do you think you've been able to
love this experience so much while other
guys have maybe struggled with it
i just love playing basketball in
general no matter where it is where it
is um
well i just say you know some guys like
the bubble just because
you know you don't have that you know
what i said earlier you don't have that
you know pressure from the opposing fans
you know
or even at home you know you don't have
that pressure from the fans to
you know that you know we'll boo you um
you know if you're not playing well and
especially if you're on the road
um you know they can get to you so
there's a little bit you have a little
bit more
ease here in the bubble not having to
worry about any of that
um but for me i just go out there and
play basketball i mean i don't really
care where it is
um you know if we're in staples i would
feel nervous if you're on the road i
would feel nervous
but once like i said once the ball tip
you know i'm fine the team is fine
we go out there and play basketball
um obviously pam and gauran let the game
early um you were talking to us
yesterday and you seem just really
excited for that match-up especially
with damn
how does it um you know hit you when you
see
an and a really good player on an
opponent go out and maybe
have the potential to miss some games
yeah i mean you never want to see a guy
get hurt
i'm not sure what their injuries are but
you you don't want to see a guy
get hurt you know you see god
work extremely hard to be here and you
know
goren and and bam are key parts of their
team
and so you know you never want to see
guys go down
like i said i don't know the
significance of the injuries but um
it always sucks you know when
not sure if they're going to play or not
and i'm not sure you're going to get the
team's best
but i mean you know we can't worry about
that we have to still go out there you
know guys came in
took their place and played extremely
well for them you know kelly olynyk came
in played well came to none
so um you know we have to worry about
the guys that's going to play and still
try to
win a series